[Musique]
ce vendredi 1er juillet a été célébré le
62e anniversaire de l'indépendance de
madagascar dans les jardins de la villa
du département
l'occasion de rappeler l'attachement de
notre département madagascar et
d'envisager une coopération encore plus
forte la coopération régionale
aujourd'hui que nous connaissons avec
l'île de madagascar à queue avec qui que
madagascar entretient des liens
privilégiés
on va continuer à progresser et le
président le départ tant ces marqueurs
annoncé justement une volonté farouche
de la part du département sur une
collaboration future caldwell agricole
notamment nous vivons des moments très
difficiles et madagascar doit revenir ce
grenier de l'océan indien et la réunion
aimerait partager avec madagascar 2
justement des échanges fructueux dans le
domaine j'espère que la coopération
entre la rijole madagascar va se
raffermir comme c'est la première fois
que je viens ici attend que fait nouveau
conseil de madagascar à la réunion ça
m'a vraiment touchée ça va nous fait moi
j'ai vu c'était c'est une agréable à une
affaire de la fête et vive la
coopération entre madagascar et la
région au programme des festivités
divers ateliers traditionnels malgaches
c'est pour faire découvrir des métiers à
ce traditionnel s'est passé à notre pays
mais m'a dit vous serez j'imagine que
votre à tuléar
comment on fait les cours ont maquillé à
différents ça nous présente à la fête à
la fin de ce midi dans l'exemple siona
mariage ou à nous traiter de la
dépendance ou à toute la fête on peut
faire maquiller comme ça alors je
représente un peu les lézards malgache
en fait tout c'est de ces choses sont
fabriqués à la main en face à ciara
match et puis les malgaches se
transforme beaucoup de
lait matériel sur place
pour faire des décorations pour faire
par exemple la société comme deux
équipes et on peut transformer ça on
plusieurs choses on peut fabriquer des
cuillères on peut faire des prêts si les
départs des vagues mais début juin
maintenant on peut fabriquer moins de 22
5 oui tout ça c'était à la main mais
aussi on travaille aussi le voir pour
transformer le coin
jouer en décoration aujourd'hui par mois
je suis heureuse de présenter
particulièrement
les poètes de madagascar vous avez des
livres assez exceptionnel et rare par
exemple
l'histoire des premiers livres ont été
écrits sur madagascar c'était
avec des personnes qui sont venus
évangéliser managa sita et donc ils ont
écrit l'histoire des rois donc vous avez
ville de ma famille qui en plus de 100
ans qui parle donc de
le distingue madagascar en français et
en malgache la soirée s'est achevée par
des danses et chants traditionnels
un moment de partage et de convivialité
une ferme où la balle
il
[Musique]